Tout comme notre frère Loïc a décidé de prêcher de manière textuelle et suivie,
qui est la forme de prédication que nous privilégions à Église Bonne Nouvelle,
c'est-à-dire que nous prêchons en nous basant sur le texte que nous lisons,
tous les enseignements que nous donnons sont tirés du texte et suivis,
c'est-à-dire que verset après verset, nous parcourons tout un livre ou toute une portion de texte biblique
en nous laissant guider par l'enseignement que le Saint-Esprit a inspiré à son auteur.
Et donc Loïc a décidé de faire cela avec l'Épître aux Hébreux,
et j'ai pensé que ce serait une bonne idée de faire la même chose avec la lettre de Jacques,
dont nous allons commencer l'étude aujourd'hui,
et donc que nous allons poursuivre verset après verset dans les futures prédications
dont j'aurai la responsabilité à Église Bonne Nouvelle.
Donc j'invite notre frère Lucas à se lever et à lire Jacques 1, des versets 1 à 4.
Jacques, c'est l'Épître des Jeux, du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
vos douze prévues qui sont dans la dispersion, salue.
Mère, regardez comme sujet déjà complète les diverses preuves auxquelles vous pouvez être exposés.
Sachant que l'épreuve de votre foi, c'est la patience,
mais il faut que la patience accomplisse parfaitement son œuvre,
afin que vous soyez parfait et à l'envie de vous, sans parler de la joie.
Le mois dernier, Dieu nous a accordé le grand privilège de célébrer plusieurs baptêmes
et d'accueillir de nouveaux membres dans notre Assemblée,
qui contre toute attente n'a jamais connu une croissance plus importante qu'en période de confinement.
Et pour cela, évidemment, nous disons gloire à Dieu et non pas à nous-mêmes.
Et cette période a été, et est toujours, parce qu'elle n'est pas finie pour nous,
une preuve supplémentaire de la fidélité du Christ envers son Église,
qu'il bâtit pierre vivante après pierre vivante.
C'est aussi une preuve pour nous de la souveraineté de Dieu à travers toutes les circonstances
que lui-même décrète pour sa gloire.
Et c'est un encouragement que Dieu nous fait à persévérer dans notre foi personnelle
et dans notre proclamation de l'Évangile, notamment en tant qu'Église.
Parce que nous avons constaté à travers les témoignages que nous avons entendus
que jusqu'à son retour, Jésus-Christ est effectivement avec nous.
Et comme il l'a promis, son Saint-Esprit combat pour nous.
Il combat en continuant à convaincre les hommes de leurs péchés,
à les conduire au pied de la glorieuse croix du calvaire.
Pour leur salut.
C'est tout cela que nous avons pu contempler dans les professions de foi débaptisées
des nouveaux membres le mois dernier.
Et je ne dis pas cela pour décourager les plus jeunes dans la foi,
mais les plus anciens le savent très bien.
Une fois baptisée, le plus dur reste à venir.
Tous ceux qui sont passés par une expérience de conversion authentique
connaissent ce sentiment d'euphorie,
ce sentiment de zèle spirituel qui manque même parfois de sagesse,
qui nous anime dans les premiers mois, voire les premières années de notre nouvelle naissance.
Dans ces moments-là, tout nous semble naturel,
tout nous semble facile dans notre marche chrétienne.
abandonner nos péchés les plus évidents,
témoigner de notre foi à chaque occasion,
participer fidèlement à la vie d'Église.
Nous n'avons que peu d'efforts à faire pour rester fidèles dans ces choses.
Dans ces moments-là de conversion et de réveil spirituel,
même l'opposition frontale,
voire la persécution la plus dure,
nous semble facile à supporter.
Lorsque le Saint-Esprit nous accorde la grâce
d'expérimenter un ou plusieurs réveils dans notre vie chrétienne,
nous ressentons la même chose qu'au moment de notre conversion.
Mais nous sommes obligés de reconnaître
que sur l'ensemble de notre vie chrétienne,
entre ces moments de réveil spirituel,
c'est plutôt la léthargie,
la lassitude,
le découragement,
voire parfois l'indifférence spirituelle
qui ont tendance à dominer.
Et cela peut grandement troubler le jeune chrétien dans la foi.
Lorsqu'il constate pour la première fois dans sa vie
un manque de motivation pour ce qui était si facile pour lui auparavant,
qu'il ne ressent pas la même chaleur
ou la même joie dans ses moments de lecture et de prière,
et dans ces moments-là peuvent venir des questions telles que
est-ce que cela veut dire que je régresse dans ma foi ?
Est-ce que ma conversion n'était finalement qu'une illusion ?
Le Seigneur m'a-t-il abandonné ?
L'apôtre Paul utilise plusieurs fois dans ses lettres des métaphores
pour illustrer la marche chrétienne dans ce monde.
Et il compare notamment le chrétien à un sportif
en évoquant la persévérance dans la sanctification.
Et pour ceux d'entre vous qui pratiqueraient un sport depuis longtemps,
vous le savez bien,
la progression dans une discipline sportive n'est pas linéaire.
Au début, on apprend vite,
on progresse beaucoup,
parce qu'on part de presque zéro.
C'est une période très gratifiante,
très motivante.
Et on a l'impression d'être promis à un très grand avenir sportif
que personne ne pourra nous arrêter sur le chemin de la victoire.
Mais il y a toujours un moment où on arrive à un palier
qui peut être plus ou moins long
et où nos progrès vont être beaucoup moins évidents.
On a l'impression de stagner
et pourtant il faut persévérer,
malgré cette impression démotivante,
jusqu'au moment où toutes les petites améliorations
difficilement acquises pendant de longs mois
nous amènent à un nouveau pic de progression
qui lui-même nous amènera à un nouveau palier
et ainsi de suite.
Autrement dit, la progression dans une discipline sportive
n'est pas linéaire,
elle est en escalier.
Et plus le sportif progresse,
plus les phases de progression sont courtes
et plus elles sont espacées par des paliers de plus en plus longs
jusqu'à ce que l'athlète atteigne son niveau maximum.
Eh bien, frères et sœurs,
je suis pour ma part convaincu
que cette image illustre bien
le progrès de notre foi dans notre marche chrétienne.
Notre vie chrétienne est essentiellement composée de paliers
qu'on peut assimiler à notre persévérance
dans les moyens de grâce au quotidien
qui sont l'étude de la parole,
la prière et la communion fraternelle dans l'Église.
Et selon sa volonté,
Dieu peut nous accorder des périodes de réveil spirituel
où nos progrès seront bien plus évidents,
ils seront plus rapides
et dans un sens plus motivant pour nous.
Mais nous ne devons pas faire l'erreur
de ne valoriser que ces moments de réveil
et de vouloir en faire la norme de notre vie.
Car par définition, ils sont exceptionnels,
ils sont ponctuels
et ils sont selon la volonté de Dieu.
Donc l'essentiel de notre vie,
ce sont ces paliers
où il nous faut persévérer,
malgré l'impression de stagnation,
parfois même de recul,
malgré la lassitude.
Tout sportif ressent cette lassitude
dans la discipline de ses entraînements.
Il souffre.
Il a à ses côtés d'autres sportifs
qui progressent plus vite que lui.
Il doute bien souvent.
Il veut laisser tomber bien souvent.
Mais il persévère.
Il persévère pour deux raisons principales.
Parce qu'il sait qu'il doit souffrir
pour progresser.
Et parce qu'il sait quel but il vise.
Il ne perd jamais des yeux la victoire.
Et c'est ce but qui est sa plus grande motivation
dans les pires moments de découragement.
Progresser pour atteindre la victoire.
Ce matin, nous allons donc parler
de la persévérance du chrétien.
Et plus particulièrement
de la persévérance du chrétien dans l'épreuve.
A l'image de ce sportif,
nous allons voir comment nous aussi
nous devons souffrir pour progresser.
Et nous allons contempler ensemble
les raisons glorieuses
que nous avons tous en commun
pour porter un regard positif
sur les épreuves de nos vies.
Et ma prière, c'est que nous tous,
aussi bien les nouveaux baptisés
que les plus anciens dans la foi,
nous ressortions de cette salle
encouragés et fortifiés
pour affronter par la grâce de Dieu toujours
les épreuves à travers lesquelles
il aura décidé de nous faire passer
pour nous préparer à la vie
dans les nouveaux cieux
et la nouvelle terre.
Et avant de nous plonger dans le vif du sujet,
puisque nous commençons
l'étude d'un nouveau texte,
nous avons besoin d'aborder
un minimum de contexte général
pour bien comprendre
toute la suite de la lettre
que nous étudierons ensemble.
Commençons donc par son auteur
qui se présente au verset 1.
Ce Jacques dont il est question,
parce qu'il y en a plusieurs
qui sont mentionnés dans la Bible,
ce Jacques n'était pas n'importe qui
puisqu'il était l'un des plus importants
responsables de l'Église
à Jérusalem à cette époque.
Il était considéré comme un des piliers
de l'Église primitive
avec Pierre et Jean.
C'est lui qui a présidé
le fameux concile de Jérusalem
qui est mentionné en Acte 15.
Et plus personnellement,
il était un des fils de Marie et Joseph,
un juif donc,
qui tout comme ses frères
était très sceptique
vis-à-vis de son demi-frère, Jésus,
tout au long de son ministère terrestre.
Et ce n'est qu'après avoir contemplé
de ses yeux
la résurrection physique du Christ
qu'il fut converti.
L'historien de l'Église primitive
égésible de Jérusalem
l'appelait Jacques le Juste
parce qu'il était un homme
d'une grande piété,
animé d'un zèle profond
pour l'obéissance de la loi de Dieu
et particulièrement dévoué à la prière.
On disait de lui
qu'il passait tant de temps
à prier sur ses genoux
que ceux-ci,
tout recouverts de cornes,
c'est-à-dire d'une peau très épaisse,
ressemblaient à ceux d'un chameau.
Voici donc qui était Jacques,
le demi-frère de Jésus,
un homme très pieux,
un homme de prière,
un pasteur,
sage et reconnu,
animé du plus profond désir
de voir ses frères et soeurs
obéir au commandement du Christ
dans tous les domaines de leur vie.
Si je vous donne ces détails,
c'est pour qu'il soit évident pour vous
qu'on ne peut pas reprocher à Jacques
de prêcher ce qu'il ne vit pas
et qu'on ne peut pas non plus
l'accuser de prêcher
une sorte de légalisme
qui serait contraire à l'évangile du Christ.
Il est au contraire
l'illustration même
des exhortations qu'il fait
à l'Église dans cette lettre.
Il est légitime,
comme Paul,
pour dire
« Soyez donc mes imitateurs ».
Tout d'abord,
il est évident que Jacques
a vécu une vraie conversion.
Voici un homme
qui a côtoyé le Christ
durant la majeure partie de sa vie
en le méprisant
et en rejetant ses enseignements.
Un homme qui,
à nouveau,
comme l'apôtre Paul,
était exemplaire
dans sa pratique du judaïsme.
Et nous voici
devant les mots
de ce juif modèle.
Après qu'il ait fait face
à son demi-frère
qui affirmait être
le fils de Dieu,
le Messie,
ce demi-frère
qu'il a vu mourir
et ressusciter
trois jours après,
nous voici devant Jacques
qui se présente
à l'Église primitive
en ces termes
au verset 1.
Serviteur de Dieu
et du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Serviteur qui a ici
le sens d'un esclave
qu'un maître a acquis
volontairement
à un grand prix
qu'il a acquis
intentionnellement.
Jacques,
un juif parlant
à des juifs,
reconnaît
qu'il a été racheté,
appelé
et qu'il est aujourd'hui
le serviteur
de son demi-frère
Jésus-Christ,
qu'il reconnaît
être vraiment Dieu
et vraiment homme.
Est-ce que ce ne sont pas là
les mots remplis
du courage
et de l'humilité
que seule une âme
illuminée
et fortifiée
par le Saint-Esprit
peut prononcer
après avoir contemplé
la gloire
du Fils de l'homme ?
Autrement dit,
par ses tout premiers mots
de présentation,
la nouvelle naissance
de Jacques est évidente
et point très important,
très important
dans toute notre étude
de cette lettre.
Toutes les exhortations
pratiques que Jacques fera
par la suite
ont pour point de départ
et pour point d'arrivée
la nouvelle nature
qu'il a reçue
en Jésus-Christ
par la grâce de Dieu.
Jacques est donc
l'illustration vivante
des paroles du Christ,
celui qui m'aime,
garde mes commandements.
Et c'est ce désir
qu'il a,
qui le guide dans sa vie,
qui transparaît
dans toute sa lettre
et qui le désire
que nous vivions nous aussi.
Une lettre
qui est donc logiquement
remplie d'exhortations
et de conseils
pour vivre
la vie chrétienne.
Vivre la vie chrétienne.
Son contenu
est beaucoup plus pratique
que théorique.
Vous vous en rendrez
facilement compte.
Jacques développe
ce qu'on appelle
l'orthopraxie
de la vie chrétienne,
c'est-à-dire
la bonne manière
de vivre devant Dieu,
la manière de vivre
droite, juste.
C'est ce que veut dire
ortho et praxie
qui veut dire pratique.
Bien sûr,
l'orthopraxie
a toujours pour base
ce qu'on appelle
l'orthodoxie,
c'est-à-dire
le bon enseignement,
la doctrine droite
et juste.
C'est-à-dire
que nous devons
d'abord connaître,
nous devons d'abord
comprendre
et accepter
ce qui est bon
pour Dieu
avant de pouvoir
pratiquer ce qui est bon
dans tous les domaines
de notre vie.
Et bien entendu,
il y a de la théorie
dans cette lettre,
il y a de l'orthodoxie
qui vient soutenir
ponctuellement
les exhortations
pratiques de Jacques.
mais elle reste avant tout
majoritairement
une lettre de conseil,
de directive pratique
sur la bonne manière
de vivre la vie chrétienne
dans ce monde.
Jacques est avant tout
épris d'un vif désir
de voir ses frères
et sœurs
faire preuve
d'une obéissance
sans compromis
à la parole de Dieu
dans tous les domaines.
Et c'est pourquoi
il aborde parfois
sans transition
des sujets très différents
tels que
l'usage de la parole,
de notre langue,
la maîtrise
de nos passions,
la gestion
des richesses
et la planification
de nos projets
de vie,
la maladie
ou encore
la lutte
contre le péché.
Cette lettre
est courte,
dense,
riche
et dans un style
qui est sans détour
direct.
Et finalement,
pour en finir
avec ce tour d'horizon
de la lettre
au verset 1,
je ne vais pas passer
beaucoup de temps
sur les destinataires
que Jacques désigne
comme étant
les douze tribus
qui sont dans la dispersion.
Certains interprètes
considèrent que Jacques
s'adresse premièrement
à ses frères juifs
convertis
qui sont dispersés
suite aux persécutions
romaines et juives.
D'autres considèrent
que ce terme
douze tribus
dans la dispersion
comme en 1 Pierre 1
fait référence
aux églises
de manière générale
que Jacques désigne
de cette manière
pour signifier
que les églises chrétiennes
sont la continuité
d'Israël,
cette fois-ci
composée de juifs
et de gentils.
Dans tous les cas,
peu importe
l'interprétation
que l'on privilégie,
ce qui est sûr,
c'est que vous et moi,
nous sommes directement
concernés
par ces exhortations
pratiques de Jacques.
Parce que cette lettre
était une lettre circulaire,
destinée non pas
à une assemblée
en particulier
pour des problèmes
particuliers,
mais à un ensemble
d'églises
composées de juifs
et de gentils
convertis au Christ
par l'Évangile.
et les problématiques
que Jacques aborde,
elles sont universelles.
Et cette lettre
est et sera toujours
très pertinente
pour l'Église
qui continuera
d'être confrontée
aux mêmes défis éthiques,
aux mêmes défis
moraux et spirituels,
jusqu'au retour
du Christ.
Ce que Jacques
veut nous rappeler,
c'est que la vie chrétienne,
ce n'est pas
que la saine doctrine,
mais c'est aussi,
sans aucun doute,
la saine pratique.
Et le sujet
avec lequel
il commence sa lettre
et qui en est finalement
le fil conducteur,
c'est la persévérance.
Et notamment
la persévérance
que produit l'épreuve
dans la vie
du chrétien.
La question
que nous allons nous poser
ce matin
face à ces versets
est la suivante.
Comment le chrétien
peut-il se réjouir
face aux épreuves
de sa vie ?
Comment
et pourquoi
le chrétien
peut-il se réjouir
face aux épreuves
de sa vie ?
La première chose
que nous devons faire
pour répondre
à cette question,
c'est définir
ce que Jacques
entend par épreuve.
Qu'est-ce que sont
ces épreuves ?
C'est très important
pour ne pas tomber
dans une compréhension
malsaine
de l'exhortation
à la joie
face aux épreuves
qu'il nous fait ici.
Au verset 2,
Jacques parle
des diverses épreuves
auxquelles
vous pouvez être exposés.
Puis juste après,
au verset 3,
il parle
de l'épreuve
de notre foi.
Comme nous l'avons dit
en introduction,
Jacques écrit
à des chrétiens
qui ont fui
la persécution
qu'ils subissaient
de la part des juifs
ou de Rome
ou même des deux
à la fois.
Donc lorsqu'il parle
des diverses épreuves
et de l'épreuve
de votre foi,
il s'agit
premièrement
des épreuves
que ses frères
endurent directement
à cause
de leur fidélité
au Seigneur Jésus-Christ
et à son évangile.
Il faut que cela
soit bien clair
pour nous tous.
Si un jour
vous entendez
un prédicateur
prendre comme base
ce verset
et vous parler
de votre patron
qui ne veut pas
vous accorder
une augmentation,
de vos résultats
entrepreneuriaux
qui ne sont pas
à la hauteur
de vos efforts
ou même
de votre conjoint
qui vous rend
la vie difficile,
vous pouvez être sûr
qu'il ne s'agit pas
de ce genre d'épreuve.
Jacques parle ici
à la suite
de notre Seigneur
qui disait
« Heureux serez-vous
lorsqu'on vous insultera,
qu'on vous persécutera
et qu'on dira
faussement de vous
toutes sortes de mal
à cause de moi.
Réjouissez-vous
et soyez dans l'allégresse
parce que
votre récompense
sera grande
au ciel. »
Et Pierre
affirmera plus tard
la même vérité
dans sa lettre.
« Réjouissez-vous
au contraire
de la part
que vous avez
aux souffrances
de Christ
afin que vous
soyez aussi
dans la joie
et dans l'allégresse
lorsque sa gloire
apparaîtra. »
Le premier point
déterminant
pour la bonne
compréhension
de ces versets
c'est donc
que les épreuves
que Jacques mentionne
ici
sont toutes
toutes
des épreuves
liées de près
ou de loin
à notre foi
en Jésus-Christ.
Ce sont
les épreuves
que vous subissez
dans le monde
parce que
vous vous réclamez
de Jésus-Christ
dans vos mots
et dans vos actes.
Les épreuves
à travers lesquelles
vous participez
aux souffrances
du Christ.
Et regardez
dans les Écritures
pour quelles raisons
et dans quel cadre
le Christ
fut persécuté.
Ce n'était pas
à cause
de son ambition
carriériste,
de son charisme
ou de son statut social
mais toujours
à cause
de son ministère
en tant que
prophète de la vérité,
fils de Dieu.
Mais je voudrais
néanmoins
nuancer un point
ici
parce qu'on me dit
souvent par rapport
à ce verset
oui mais il est
quand même question
de diverses épreuves
auxquelles nous
sommes exposés.
Est-ce que ça
n'inclut pas
toutes les difficultés
auxquelles nous
pouvons faire face
dans la vie ?
Le verset 3
nous permet de répondre
à cette question.
On reconnaît
le type d'épreuves
dont Jacques parle
non seulement
au fait
que nous les subissons
à cause de notre
fidélité au Christ
mais nous les reconnaissons
aussi
aux fruits
que ces épreuves
produisent en nous
et ce fruit
c'est la persévérance.
Laissez-moi
vous donner
quelques exemples
concrets
pour illustrer cela.
On peut classer
les épreuves
dans la vie chrétienne
en gros
en trois catégories.
La première catégorie
d'épreuves
dans la vie chrétienne
c'est
la persécution directe
explicite
intentionnelle.
C'est l'épreuve
de notre foi
la plus évidente
que nous pouvons subir.
C'est la persécution directe
à cause
de nos croyances
et de notre mode
de vie chrétien
comme ce fut le cas
depuis l'église primitive
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
dans de très nombreux pays.
C'est même
plutôt la norme
pour les chrétiens
que l'inverse.
Lorsque nous sommes
insultés
agressés
opprimés
ou tués
parce que nous sommes
chrétiens
nous traversons
évidemment
ce type d'épreuve
liée au nom du Christ
qui produit
de la persévérance
et qui a pour finalité
la récompense céleste.
Ce sont les trois
caractéristiques
que vous devez garder
en tête
pour reconnaître
une épreuve
telle qu'elles sont décrites
dans la parole.
les épreuves
du chrétien
elles sont liées
au nom du Christ
elles produisent
de la persévérance
et elles ont
pour finalité
la récompense
céleste.
La deuxième
catégorie
d'épreuve
à laquelle nous sommes
plus confrontés
dans un pays
comme la France
c'est celle
de la persécution
indirecte
c'est un terme
qui vient de moi
c'est pas un terme
officiel
les épreuves
qui sont
la conséquence
qui sont un effet
secondaire
dirons-nous
de notre obéissance
à la volonté
de Dieu.
Par exemple
un frère
qui cherche
depuis longtemps
un travail
et qui refuse
une opportunité
pourtant prometteuse
parce que cet emploi
impliquerait
qu'il doive travailler
le dimanche
il est éprouvé
à cause de sa foi.
Un frère
qui refuse
une promotion
parce que son nouveau
poste
exigerait de lui
d'être beaucoup moins disponible
pour sa famille
il est éprouvé
à cause de sa foi.
Un adolescent
qui se prononce
aujourd'hui
contre l'homosexualité
ou qui attend
d'être marié
avec une chrétienne
pour avoir
des rapports sexuels
et qui est mis
à l'écart
qui est moqué
par les autres élèves
voire pointé du doigt
par les enseignants
il est éprouvé
à cause de sa foi.
Tous ces choix
dans ces exemples
peuvent amener
une famille
à vivre modestement
alors qu'elle
pourrait s'enrichir
en travaillant
le dimanche
en acceptant
un emploi
qui le rende
indisponible
pour sa famille.
Ces choix
peuvent amener
une personne
à se retrouver
isolée
mal vue des autres
tout simplement
parce qu'elle obéit
à la volonté
de Dieu
et ces épreuves
sont aussi liées
au nom du Christ
elles produisent
aussi de la persévérance
et elles ont pour finalité
la récompense céleste.
Et il y a finalement
une troisième
catégorie
d'épreuves
que Christian
a abordé
dans son introduction
qui sont les épreuves
communes
à tous les hommes.
Ce sont
les diverses épreuves
auxquelles le chrétien
peut être confronté
au même titre
que le non-croyant.
Mais la différence
c'est précisément
parce que nous sommes
chrétiens
le Saint-Esprit
nous travaille
à travers ces épreuves
communes
pour produire en nous
de la patience
de la persévérance.
Et donc
en effet
on peut dire
que pour le chrétien
par le Saint-Esprit
toutes les épreuves
de sa vie
produisent
de la patience
de la persévérance
et donc
à ce titre
elles doivent être
considérées par lui
comme un sujet
de joie complète.
La même épreuve
qui produit
chez le non-chrétien
de la colère
de la frustration
du désespoir
produira
chez le chrétien
par le Saint-Esprit
pas par lui-même
de la patience
de la persévérance
et de la joie
parce qu'il sait
que cela travaille
à sa sanctification
et que la finalité
de toutes ces épreuves
c'est la félicité
éternelle
auprès de Dieu.
A ce jour
en France
nous sommes
beaucoup plus susceptibles
de traverser
les deux dernières
catégories
d'épreuves.
Et laissez-moi vous dire
que le plus grand danger
pour nous frères et sœurs
dans ce pays
ce n'est pas
l'épreuve
de la persécution
mais plutôt
le danger
du confort.
Je me souviens
avoir lu
quelque part
cette phrase
« Si votre vie
chrétienne
est confortable
c'est qu'il y a
un problème ».
Et nous devons
sérieusement
nous poser la question
« Est-ce que je m'arrange
avec ma conscience
pour que ma vie
chrétienne
soit la plus confortable
possible ? »
Est-ce que dès que je suis
confronté à un choix
où je sais très bien
que si j'obéis à la volonté
de Dieu
je serai éprouvé
est-ce que je m'arrange
avec moi-même
pour choisir la voie
du compromis
et de la facilité ?
A quand remonte
la dernière fois
où vous avez été éprouvés
à cause de votre foi ?
Si nous ne pouvons pas
répondre à cette question
remettons-nous en question
et prions pour que Dieu
nous montre
s'il n'y a pas
des domaines
de notre vie
où nous nous sommes
progressivement endurcis
par crainte de l'épreuve
par facilité
et désir
de confort.
Notre Seigneur
nous a avertis
que nous serions
éprouvés dans ce monde
à cause de notre foi en lui
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Si cela ne nous est
jamais arrivé
il est probable
que nous ne soyons pas
ses disciples.
Le monde et Satan
ne sont pas dérangés
par une foi silencieuse
intérieure
invisible
purement individuelle
comme nous y encourage
notre société aujourd'hui.
C'est lorsqu'elle s'exprime
qu'elle dérange
qu'elle génère une opposition
et donc
de la persécution.
c'est pourquoi
si nous n'avons jamais
vécu dans une certaine mesure
la persécution
l'opposition
c'est que notre foi
ne se traduit
ni en parole
ni en actes
dans notre vie
et donc
qu'elle n'est possiblement
pas la foi
biblique.
Le plus grand danger
aujourd'hui pour nous
chrétiens en Occident
ce n'est pas la persécution
c'est le confort
et l'assoupissement spirituel
qui l'amène
dans notre vie
et nous devons y être
particulièrement
vigilants.
Voilà donc
les diverses épreuves
dont parle Jacques
et qu'il nous appelle
à regarder
comme un sujet
de joie
complète.
Ce sont les situations
qui éprouvent
de près ou de loin
votre foi
en Jésus Christ.
Et il est crucial
de nous arrêter
sur cette exhortation
à la joie
pour bien comprendre
ce que Jacques
veut nous dire
parce que là
nous rentrons vraiment
dans le cœur du sujet.
Nous touchons vraiment
au rapport unique
que seul le chrétien
peut entretenir
avec les épreuves
de la vie.
Maintenant que nous avons vu
ce que sont les épreuves
que faire face à l'épreuve ?
Quelle est l'exhortation
de Jacques ?
Avant toute chose
voyons ce qu'il ne nous dit pas
avant de voir
ce qu'il nous dit.
Tout d'abord
Jacques ne nous invite pas
à être dans le déni
face à l'épreuve.
A détourner le regard
en faisant comme
si elle n'existait pas.
Ou comme si elle n'impliquait pas
une réelle souffrance
dans notre vie.
Il ne nous encourage pas
à la pensée positive.
A nous auto-convaincre
par des proclamations
que tout va bien
alors que
évidemment
nous souffrons.
Le chemin de la vraie joie
n'est pas le déni.
Il nous suffit
de lire les psaumes de David
pour comprendre
que Dieu n'exige pas
de ses enfants
qu'il nie la souffrance
qui est une réalité
dans ce monde
et dans notre vie.
Le chrétien
comme tout être humain
fait face
à l'épreuve
à la souffrance
à la tristesse
à la détresse
au désespoir
au découragement
et parfois même
à la dépression.
Et il ne s'agit
en aucun cas
de nier cet état de fait.
C'est la première chose
que Jacques ne nous demande pas
de faire.
Nier l'épreuve,
nier la souffrance.
Il ne nous invite pas
non plus
à désirer l'épreuve
pour elle-même.
Il ne nous invite pas
à vouloir
à désirer la souffrance.
Nous ne sommes pas appelés
ni par Jacques
ni par Dieu lui-même
à chercher
par tous les moyens
la persécution.
Croyez-moi,
c'est déjà bien assez
de la supporter
lorsqu'elle vient
à nous naturellement.
Nous n'avons pas besoin
de la chercher.
Le chrétien n'est pas
un sadique
qui aime souffrir.
Il ne pratique pas
l'autoflagellation.
Le chemin de la vraie joie
n'est pas la souffrance
qu'elle soit physique
ou morale.
Même mourir
en martyr
n'a aucun sens
et ne sert à rien
si ce n'est pas lié
à notre amour
et notre fidélité
au Christ.
C'est ce que dit Paul
en 1 Corinthiens 13
au verset 3
au sujet de l'amour
lorsqu'il parle
de l'amour
et de la charité.
Il dit
« Quand je distribuerai
tous mes biens
pour la nourriture
des pauvres,
quand je livrerai
même mon corps
pour être brûlé,
si je n'ai pas
la charité,
cela ne me sert
de rien. »
Ce que cela veut dire
c'est que la souffrance
en elle-même
ne sert à rien
si elle n'éprouve
pas notre foi
en nous sanctifiant.
La souffrance
déconnectée
de notre sanctification
n'a aucune utilité.
Et à l'inverse,
Jacques ne nous invite
évidemment pas
à fuir l'épreuve
à tout prix.
C'est la troisième chose
qu'il ne nous dit pas.
Comme si elle n'avait
aucune raison d'être
dans la vie chrétienne.
Comme si
plus un chrétien
était mature
et béni par Dieu,
moins il souffrait,
moins il était censé
souffrir.
Et c'est pourtant
ce que l'on entend
souvent
dans la bouche
des faux prophètes,
du faux évangile
de prospérité.
Le chemin
de la vraie joie,
ce n'est pas
une vie sans épreuve.
Le chemin
de la vraie joie,
ce n'est pas
une vie
sans aucune épreuve.
À partir du moment
où vous considérez
que la souffrance
est une anomalie
dans la vie chrétienne,
vous posez le pied
sur la pente
extrêmement glissante
du murmure
contre Dieu,
de l'instabilité
et de la superficialité
spirituelle.
La souffrance
a toute sa place
dans notre vie chrétienne.
L'anomalie,
ce n'est pas
une vie
avec des épreuves,
mais bien
une vie facile,
calme
et sans vagues.
Frères et sœurs,
une vie sans épreuve,
dans l'immense majorité
des cas,
ce n'est pas
une bénédiction,
c'est plutôt
un jugement
de la part de Dieu.
Car c'est au travail
du Saint-Esprit
dans votre être intérieur,
à travers les épreuves
que nous reconnaissons
la discipline paternelle
salvatrice
de notre Père Céleste.
C'est ainsi
que le psalmiste
peut dire
« Peuple,
bénissez notre Dieu,
faites retentir
sa louange.
Il a conservé
la vie
à notre âme
et il n'a pas permis
que notre pied
chante cela.
Car tu nous as
éprouvés,
ô Dieu,
tu nous as éprouvés,
tu nous as fait passer
au creuset
comme l'argent,
tu nous as amenés
dans le filet,
tu as mis sur nos reins
un pesant fardeau,
tu as fait monter
des hommes
sur nos têtes,
nous avons passé
par le feu
et par l'eau,
mais tu nous en as tirés
pour nous donner
l'abondance. »
Et c'est ainsi
que l'auteur
de l'Épître aux Hébreux
nous adresse
cette magnifique
exhortation
face à la persécution.
« Vous avez oublié
l'exhortation
qui s'adresse à vous
comme à des fils.
Mon fils,
ne méprise pas
la discipline du Seigneur
et ne perds pas courage
quand tu es repris
par lui
car celui
que le Seigneur
aime,
il le discipline
et il fouette
tout fils
qu'il agrée.
vous endurez
des peines
comme discipline.
Dieu agit
envers vous
comme envers
des fils
car qui est le fils
que le Père
ne discipline pas ?
Mais si vous êtes
sans la discipline
à laquelle
tous participent,
alors vous êtes
des bâtards
et non pas
des fils.
De plus,
nous avons eu
les Pères
de notre chair
pour nous discipliner
et nous les avons respectés.
Ne serons-nous
pas beaucoup plus
soumis
au Père des Esprits
et nous vivrons
car cela disciplinait
pendant peu de jours
selon qu'il le trouvait bon
mais celui-ci
nous discipline
pour notre profit
afin que nous
participions
à sa sainteté.
Or,
aucune discipline
pour le présent
ne semble être
un sujet de joie
mais de tristesse
mais plus tard
elle rend
le fruit paisible
de la justice
à ceux
qui sont exercés
par elle.
Amen.
La souffrance
a toute sa place
dans la vie chrétienne
car c'est par elle
que Dieu
accomplit en nous
l'objectif
le plus noble
qui soit
celui de nous rendre
conformes
à l'image
de son Fils unique
Jésus-Christ.
Et donc finalement
ce que Jacques
nous appelle à faire
face aux épreuves
réelles de notre vie
ce n'est ni de les nier
ni de les rechercher
à tout prix
ni de les fuir
mais c'est de les affronter
avec courage
en posant
un certain regard
sur elles.
Jacques nous encourage
à considérer
les épreuves
à les regarder
à les voir
comme quelque chose
de positif
à cause
de ce qu'elles produisent
en nous
et du but
que Dieu a
lorsqu'il nous éprouve.
Est-ce que vous comprenez
bien la différence ?
Une épreuve
reste une épreuve.
La souffrance
reste la souffrance.
Nous ne changeons pas
les définitions
mais en tant que chrétien
nous disposons
d'un cadre
bien précis
qui nous permet
réellement
et sincèrement
de porter
un regard
positif
sur ces épreuves
parce que nous savons
que Dieu les décrète
et les utilise
pour nous sanctifier
et pour nous guider
vers la Jérusalem céleste.
Et cela ne donne pas seulement
un sens
aux épreuves
de notre vie
ce qui est déjà pas mal
mais bien plus que cela
cela leur donne
un sens positif
et même un sens
désirable
pour le chrétien.
Ce qui fait notre joie
et que nous désirons
ce n'est pas
l'épreuve en elle-même
mais c'est bien
le fruit spirituel
de la persévérance
que Dieu cultive en nous
afin de nous guider
vers la glorieuse destination
de la vie éternelle.
Et c'est ce que nous allons
considérer maintenant
pour que nous aussi
nous puissions
non de manière hypocrite
et éphémère
mais en toute sincérité
nous réjouir
de ce fruit de persévérance
que produit l'épreuve
dans nos vies.
Maintenant que nous avons vu
ce que sont les épreuves
ce que Jacques nous invite
à faire face aux épreuves
voyons comment nous pouvons
apprécier
l'épreuve
la voir comme quelque chose
de positif
la considérer
comme un sujet
de joie
complète.
Nous savons donc
que les épreuves
de notre vie
sont bénéfiques
parce que
elles produisent
de la persévérance
mais
la persévérance
en elle-même
n'a un intérêt
n'a de la valeur
que parce que
elle aussi
elle accomplit
une œuvre
dans nos vies
de sanctification.
Relisons
le verset 4
Mais il faut
que la patience
accomplisse
parfaitement
son œuvre
afin que vous
soyez parfait
et accompli
sans faillir
en rien.
Ce n'est donc pas
l'épreuve en elle-même
qui est bénéfique
ce n'est pas
non plus
la persévérance
en elle-même
qui est bénéfique
mais bien
le résultat
que nous obtenons
grâce au Saint-Esprit
lorsque nous
patientons
dans l'épreuve
et que nous
ne la fuyons pas.
Ce qui est bénéfique
à la fin
c'est le fruit
produit
par la persévérance.
Et donc
dans cette dernière partie
sur le verset 4
je voudrais
vous présenter
quelques bénéfices
extrêmement précieux
que la persévérance
a pour nous
chrétiens.
Des bénéfices
qu'en effet
nous devrions chérir
plus que tout
et qui donc
devraient nous permettre
de nous réjouir
face à l'épreuve
comme Jacques nous y exhorte
car c'est par l'épreuve
que ces bénéfices
sont produits
dans notre vie.
Le premier ensemble
de bénéfices spirituels
produit par la persévérance
que je voudrais
vous présenter
concerne notre union
et notre intimité
avec le Christ.
Lorsque nous persévérons
dans l'épreuve
nous participons
aux souffrances
de notre Sauveur
et Seigneur Jésus.
Et lorsque nous sommes
persécutés
il nous accorde
le grand privilège
d'être associés
à son glorieux nom.
Lorsque nous voyons
dans un livre
ou un film
ce personnage
qui est honoré
de pouvoir souffrir
voire même
de pouvoir donner sa vie
par fidélité
à son roi
ou son pays
c'est une bonne image
du privilège
que le Christ
nous accorde
et ce privilège
que nous devrions ressentir
lorsque nous souffrons
à cause de son nom
parce que nous sommes
associés
au nom le plus glorieux
que cette terre
n'ait jamais connue.
C'est un honneur
d'être unis
au Christ
dans la persécution.
Deuxième privilège
bénéfice
pardon
l'épreuve
approfondit
notre intimité
avec le Christ
parce qu'elle nous pousse
à la prière.
Nous sommes obligés
de reconnaître
que nous ne prions
jamais avec autant
de zèle
qu'au milieu
de l'épreuve
parce qu'elle nous pousse
à dépendre concrètement
de la providence
de Dieu
alors que les temps
de répit
ont tendance
à nous conforter
dans une fausse assurance
d'indépendance
et de contrôle
de notre vie.
Il n'y a rien
de plus efficace
que l'épreuve
pour vaincre
l'orgueil
de notre chair
parce que l'épreuve
nous oblige
à reconnaître
nos limites
et à dépendre
de la toute puissance
de Dieu
et elle nous pousse
à la prière.
Troisième bénéfice,
l'épreuve approfondit
notre intimité
avec le Christ
parce qu'elle nous fait
aspirer après son secours
et sa délivrance
qu'elle soit terrestre
ou éternelle.
Autrement dit,
la persévérance
dans l'épreuve
produit en nous
de l'espérance.
Et pour citer
un ami
qui écrit
sur le blog
Par la foi
qui a écrit
de merveilleux articles
sur le sujet
de la souffrance,
il a écrit
« La souffrance
a pour but
de nous faire vivre
toujours plus
en espérance des cieux,
de la gloire
et de l'éternité.
Ayant notre paille
brûlée,
nos bords polis
et notre faiblesse
transformée
en la puissance
du Seigneur,
nous nous retrouvons
en train de vivre
et respirer
l'espérance
de la gloire de Dieu.
C'est par cette espérance
que nous sommes prêts
à tout donner,
à tout sacrifier
et à tout souffrir
pour Christ.
Et dernier
bénéfice,
en persévérant
dans l'épreuve,
nous faisons
le bon plaisir
de Dieu.
Nous plaisons
au cœur
de notre Dieu
lorsque nous persévérons
dans l'épreuve
et cette seule raison
devrait nous suffire
à considérer
l'épreuve
comme un sujet
de joie complète.
Dieu ne se réjouit
pas de notre souffrance
mais il prend plaisir
dans le fait
que nous suivions
les pas de son Fils,
que nous comptions
sur lui
pour avancer
et que par sa grâce
nous grandissions
en sanctification.
Deuxième
ensemble
de bénéfices,
persévérir
dans l'épreuve
est également
un très bon moyen
pour nous
de grandir
dans l'assurance
de notre salut.
Le premier ensemble,
l'intimité avec le Christ,
le deuxième ensemble,
grandir dans l'assurance
de notre salut
parce que lorsque
nous persévérons
dans l'épreuve,
la force
et la qualité
de notre foi
augmentent
et cela démontre
son authenticité.
Les épreuves
sont un excellent moyen
de renforcer
notre assurance
du salut.
Lorsque nous constatons
que dans les pires
moments de notre vie,
le Saint-Esprit
nous soutient
et nous permet
de ne pas murmurer
contre Dieu,
mais au contraire,
d'en ressortir
plus affermis
que nous ne l'étions
au départ,
avec une intimité
plus profonde
entre Dieu
et nous.
Lorsque nous persévérons
dans l'épreuve,
nous sommes assurés
de notre filiation
divine.
Deuxième point
pour l'assurance
de notre salut.
Nous sommes assurés
de notre filiation divine
comme nous l'avons lu
dans l'Épître aux Hébreux
parce que Dieu
nous confirme par là
qu'il nous discipline,
qu'il nous éduque
et donc qu'il nous aime
comme un père.
L'épreuve
ne détruit pas
le chrétien,
elle le sanctifie
et elle le perfectionne.
Mon fils ne méprise pas
la discipline du Seigneur
et ne perd pas courage
car tu es repris par lui,
car celui que le Seigneur aime,
il le discipline
et il fouet tout fils
qui l'agrée.
Troisième ensemble
de bénéfices,
il concerne
la transformation
de notre caractère.
La persévérance,
comme nous l'avons lu,
fait une œuvre en nous
afin que nous soyons parfaits
et accomplis sans faillir en rien
et donc notre caractère
se retrouve transformé
lorsque nous persévérons
dans l'épreuve.
Premier bénéfice,
Dieu nous façonne
à l'image de son Fils.
Son Fils qui a lui-même
souffert bien des tourments
dans le but d'accomplir
la justice
dans la même chair que nous.
Si Jésus a dû porter sa croix,
traverser le désert
et souffrir à cause
de sa fidélité
envers son Père,
pourquoi en serait-il
autrement pour nous,
ses disciples ?
Et n'est-ce pas
le plus grand des privilèges
que d'être façonné
par les mains du Père
à l'image du Fils
par le Saint-Esprit ?
N'est-ce pas
le plus grand privilège
d'être l'œuvre
des mains
du Dieu trinitaire ?
L'épreuve est un outil
entre les mains du potier
pour modeler
les vases d'argile
que nous sommes
à l'image parfaite
du Fils unique.
Deuxième bénéfice
pour notre transformation
de caractère,
lorsque nous persévérons
dans l'épreuve,
Dieu se glorifie
à travers notre faiblesse.
Notre orgueil
est vaincu
et notre Dieu
est glorifié.
Nous diminuons
et il est élevé.
En cela,
l'épreuve nous permet
d'accomplir
le plus grand but
de notre existence,
à savoir glorifier Dieu
tout en grandissant
en humilité.
Troisième bénéfice,
en persévérant
dans l'épreuve,
nous rendons
un beau témoignage,
surprenant,
parfois incompréhensible
et souvent attirant
pour le monde,
que seul le chrétien
peut rendre
par le Saint-Esprit.
L'endurance
dans l'épreuve
et non la prospérité
est certainement
le moyen
d'évangélisation pratique
le plus puissant
dont le chrétien
dispose dans ce monde.
Quatrième bénéfice,
lorsque nous sortons
victorieux
d'une épreuve,
nous sommes mieux
préparés
à affronter
la prochaine.
Nous affûtons
nos armes spirituelles
pour le prochain combat.
Nous devenons
des hommes
et des femmes
plus mûrs
et stables
dans notre foi.
Nous résistons mieux
aux épreuves
pour nous-mêmes
et nous sommes plus
à même
d'aider nos frères
et sœurs
dans la bataille
lorsque eux aussi
traverseront
des épreuves.
Dernier bénéfice
lié à notre
transformation
de caractère,
de manière générale,
la persévérance
dans l'épreuve
produit en nous
un caractère pieux,
équilibré
et vertueux.
Désirons-nous
travailler
à notre sanctification
comme Paul nous invite
en philippien ?
Alors persévérons
dans l'épreuve.
Un autre ensemble
de bénéfices
concerne
la communion fraternelle.
Notre vie
non pas seulement
personnelle
mais communautaire.
Notre persévérance
dans l'épreuve
n'a pas que
des bénéfices
pour nous
mais pour le corps
du Christ tout entier.
Lorsque nous
persévérons
dans l'épreuve,
cela nous rend
capables de soutenir
et d'encourager
d'autres frères et sœurs
lorsqu'ils sont éprouvés
à leur tour.
Bien sûr,
nous pouvons comprendre,
nous pouvons compatir
et encourager
ceux qui souffrent
sans être passés
par les mêmes souffrances.
Mais s'il est dit
du Seigneur Jésus
lui-même
en Hébreu 4
au verset 15
Car nous n'avons pas
un souverain sacrificateur
qui ne puisse
compatir
à nos faiblesses
au contraire
il a été tenté
comme nous
en toutes choses
sans commettre
de péché.
Si cela est vrai
pour le Christ
à combien
plus forte raison
cela est-il vrai
pour nous aussi
que nous serons
davantage capables
de soutenir
un frère
une sœur
dans l'épreuve
en l'ayant nous-mêmes
traversé
par la grâce de Dieu.
Et le deuxième bénéfice
qui concerne
la communion fraternelle
c'est que les épreuves
que nous traversons
resserrent
nos liens fraternels
ils affermissent
par là
ils fortifient
le corps du Christ
l'assemblée locale
plus le corps
du Christ
participe
à ses souffrances
et persévère
dans l'épreuve
plus il resplendit
de son éclat
aux yeux du monde
plus il est une lumière
dans les ténèbres
de ce monde.
Et dernier bénéfice
de notre persévérance
dans l'épreuve
une des caractéristiques
de l'épreuve
frères et sœurs
que paradoxalement
nous avons tendance
à oublier
c'est qu'elle prendra fin
que ce soit
dans cette vie
ou dans l'éternité
ne perdez pas courage
lorsque vous êtes
dans l'épreuve
car Dieu a déjà prévu
le moyen pour vous
d'en sortir
parfois nous pouvons
avoir l'impression
que nous n'en sortirons
jamais
mais cela ne nous fait
qu'espérer
et chérir davantage
notre libération
et notre consolation
éternelle
auprès de Jésus Christ.
Voici donc
quelques précieux bénéfices
que nous recevons
lorsque fortifiés
par le Saint-Esprit
nous tenons bons
dans l'épreuve
et nous en sortons
victorieux.
Est-ce que cette liste
non exhaustive
vous attire ?
Est-ce que vous considérez
ces fruits produits
par la persévérance
comme de véritables bénéfices
non seulement
désirables
chérissables
mais aussi nécessaires
pour votre sanctification ?
Est-ce que ces bénéfices
s'ils en sont pour vous
pèsent plus lourd
dans la balance
que les sacrifices
et la souffrance
que vous devez traverser
pour les obtenir ?
Est-ce que vous êtes
dans la joie
lorsque vous méditez
sur ces bénéfices
même si vous êtes
éprouvé dans votre vie ?
Je ne parle pas
d'une joie extérieure
exubérante
je parle d'une paix
d'une sérénité
d'une joie intérieure
profonde
que seuls nous chrétiens
avons le privilège
d'expérimenter.
Si ces bénéfices
ne vous attirent pas
examinez les priorités
de votre cœur
car le désir suprême
d'un cœur régénéré
c'est de grandir
à la ressemblance
du Christ
et en intimité
avec lui
et avec son Église.
Le cœur
qui préfère
le confort
à l'épreuve
même si cela implique
de renoncer au Christ
et à son Église
est un cœur
idolâtre
car il y a
dans ce cœur
une place plus importante
pour le confort
que pour la fidélité
au Christ.
Mais nous devons tous
reconnaître que malgré tout
même en comprenant
tous les précieux bénéfices
de la persévérance
dans l'épreuve
la plupart du temps
nous n'arrivons pas
à considérer
la souffrance
comme un sujet
de joie complète.
C'est un processus
qui prend du temps.
Se réjouir dans l'épreuve
est une des marques
les plus fortes
et évidentes
de la maturité spirituelle
et cette maturité
se développe
progressivement
épreuve
après épreuve
alors prions
pour que le Saint-Esprit
nous soutienne
tout au long du chemin
qu'il nous fasse
chérir plus que tout
le fait d'être modelé
à l'image
de notre Sauveur
qui a lui-même
tant souffert
pour que nous soyons
à jamais délivrés
de notre péché
qui a lui-même
souffert les pires épreuves
pour que nous
puissions
expérimenter
cette sanctification.
Je voudrais conclure
avec une note
d'encouragement.
Comme l'a écrit
l'auteur de la lettre
aux Hébreux
« Aucune discipline
pour le présent
ne semble être
un sujet de joie
mais de tristesse
mais plus tard
elle rend le fruit
paisible de la justice
à ceux qui sont
exercés par elle. »
J'avais vraiment
à l'esprit
les nouveaux baptisés
pendant la préparation
de ce serment.
Notre Dieu
est honnête
et sincère
avec nous.
Il nous éprouvera.
Vous passerez
par des moments
difficiles.
Parfois
vous aurez l'impression
que rien de ce que
vous vivez
n'a d'utilité
ou même de sens.
Vous vous direz
« C'est vraiment ça
la vie chrétienne ?
À quoi cela sert-il
que je passe
par tant de souffrance ? »
Mais dans ces moments-là
rappelez-vous
l'œuvre glorieuse
que notre Dieu
sage,
bon
et patient
opère en vous
par l'épreuve.
Comme le sportif
qui ne supporte plus
de répéter
encore et encore
les mêmes exercices
ne perdez jamais
de vue l'objectif.
La vie éternelle
dans les nouveaux cieux
et la nouvelle terre
là où plus
aucune larme
ne coulera
car Jésus-Christ
les aura définitivement
essuyés
de votre visage.
Jacques parle beaucoup
dans sa lettre
du jour
du retour
du Seigneur.
Non pour en débattre
théologiquement
mais parce qu'il sait
que c'est pour nous
la plus grande source
de motivation
pour travailler
à notre sanctification
dans la joie
et dans l'espérance.
Alors dans l'attente
de son retour
appliquons les exhortations
de Jacques.
Ne cherchons pas
la persécution
et l'épreuve
pour nous prouver
quoi que ce soit.
Mettons plutôt
tous nos efforts
à vivre
une vie de fidélité
au commandement du Christ
dans notre quotidien
pour nous fortifier
spirituellement
afin d'être prêts
lorsque la persécution
viendra à nous
car elle viendra à nous
alors préparons-nous.
Ne voyons pas
la souffrance
comme un jugement
ou une anomalie
lorsque Dieu
la décrète
dans notre vie.
Christ l'a subi
et Dieu l'a établi
comme un outil nécessaire
de sanctification
dans nos vies.
Rappelez-vous
que l'épreuve
n'est jamais séparée
de l'amour de Dieu
pour vous.
Si vous êtes unis
au Christ par la foi
Dieu ne cessera
jamais de vous aimer.
Il ne peut vous aimer
plus ou moins
en tout temps
et en toutes circonstances.
Il vous aime
de l'amour éternel
et parfait
qu'il a pour son
Fils unique.
Au milieu de l'épreuve
ne doutez jamais
de l'amour de Dieu
à votre égard.
Pour ceux d'entre nous
qui traversent
une oasis
dans leur vie
n'oubliez pas
que l'oasis
est l'anomalie
et que le désert
est la norme.
Profitez du temps
de répit
non pour vous assoupir
ou vous ramollir
spirituellement
mais pour aiguiser
vos armes.
Préparez votre armure
en vue du prochain combat
par la prière
l'étude
de la parole de Dieu
et la communion fraternelle.
Pour ceux d'entre nous
qui ont peur
ou qui sont fragiles
sachez que Dieu
ne nous tente pas
au-dessus de nos forces.
Il a prévu la solution
pour sortir de l'épreuve.
Il ne fait pas cela
pour vous accabler
ou vous détruire
mais pour vous faire grandir
et vous fortifier.
Pour ceux d'entre nous
qui ont échoué
face à l'épreuve
dans le passé
qui ont baissé
les bras
face à la difficulté
et qui ont laissé
l'épreuve
se transformer en tentation
puis en péché
sachez que Dieu
est fidèle et juste
pour vous pardonner.
Ne laissez pas Satan
vous faire croire
que vous n'êtes pas
dignes du pardon de Dieu
mais confessez
votre péché devant Dieu.
Revenez de vos mauvaises voies
et reprenez la course.
Jésus-Christ est sorti
victorieux de toutes
les épreuves
afin de vous justifier
devant Dieu
par le moyen de la foi.
Tant qu'il vous accorde
la vie
il n'est pas trop tard.
Repentez-vous
prenez courage
et revenez vers Christ
il vous soutiendra.
Pour ceux d'entre nous
qui sont au beau milieu
de l'épreuve
n'oubliez pas
qu'elle s'arrêtera.
Ce n'est pas
votre destinée éternelle
au contraire
portez le regard
sur l'objectif
vous sanctifiez
pour vous préparer
à la vie éternelle.
Ces épreuves
sont de courte durée
face
à l'éternité
et Dieu
vous consolera
infiniment au-delà
des souffrances
que vous endurez
actuellement.
Patientez
et persévérez
en vaut la peine.
Pour supporter cela
nous avons absolument
besoin de prière
et de nos frères et sœurs
et c'est ce que nous verrons
dans la prochaine prédication.
Ainsi donc
nous répondons
à notre question
initiale.
Comment
le chrétien
peut-il se réjouir
face aux épreuves
même les plus dures
de sa vie ?
En mettant
en face
de la souffrance
tous les bénéfices
présents
et éternels
que sa persévérance
produira
grâce au Saint-Esprit
au nom du Christ
et à la gloire
du Père.
Avant de prier
je voudrais lire
Romains 5
verset 3 à 4
comme conclusion
de cette prédication.
Bien plus
nous nous glorifions
même des afflictions
sachant que
l'affliction
produit la persévérance
la persévérance
la victoire
dans l'épreuve
et cette victoire
l'espérance.
Amen.
Prions.
Seigneur Jésus Christ
nous te disons
merci
pour toutes les souffrances
que tu as supportées
par pure grâce
parce que tu l'as voulu
et décidé
pour que nous puissions
être justifiés
par toi
réconciliés
avec le Père
et sanctifiés
par le Saint-Esprit.
Merci de ne pas
nous avoir
caché les difficultés
auxquelles nous ferions face
en marchant
à ta suite
dans ce monde.
Et merci
car tu ne nous as pas
laissés seuls
face à l'épreuve
mais tu nous as envoyé
le Saint-Esprit
comme consolateurs.
pardonne-nous
pour notre faiblesse
pour notre manque
de zèle
et de désir
pour notre sanctification
tu nous as sauvés
pour que nous soyons saints
régénérés
à ton image
d'homme parfait
que le Saint-Esprit
travaille nos cœurs
afin que cet objectif
de vie
soit le plus élevé
dans nos cœurs
afin que nous puissions
endurer les épreuves
avec la joie paisible
du chrétien mature
Seigneur
nous comptons
sur ta force
dans notre marche
vers ta cité céleste
soutiens-nous
et garde-nous
unis en Jésus-Christ
jusqu'à la fin
c'est en son nom
que nous prions
Amen
Ayez un bon dimanche
une bonne semaine
fortifiée par
ces encouragements
à travers
les épreuves
que vous pourriez
traverser
les épreuves